de toute façon tout ce qu'il fait à
l'opinion contre lui donc il va venir
nous exposer faire de la communication
ce qui s'est très bien faire mais sur le
fond il va proposer quoi moi je reste de
toute manière comme la grande majorité
des Français attachée à la satisfaction
d'un mot d'ordre le retrait vendredi 14
avril le conseil est constitutionnel a
validé pour l'essentiel la loi sur nos
retraites et je l'ai donc logiquement
promulgué le président a tout fait pour
que l'on attend de rien du tout de son
allocation il a tout fait pour que le
lien soit rompu ces changements étaient
donc nécessaires et constitue un effort
c'est vrai j'attends d'un président de
la République dans la situation dans
laquelle nous nous trouvons qu'il
atterrissent qu'il atterrissent
c'est-à-dire qu'ils comprennent que les
Français ne veulent pas transformer les
deux pires années de travail en enfin
les deux plus belles années pardon de la
retraite en deux pires années de travail
c'est toute cette colère que de très
nombreux Français ont exprimé en
manifestants et pour l'immense majorité
dans le calme et le respect de nos
institutions
personne et surtout pas moi ne peut
rester sourd à cette revendication de
justice sociale et de rénovation de
notre vie démocratique qui va être
encore dans un exercice que je vais
qualifier ne le sait pas une attaque
personnelle quoi que d'arrogance
politique on a on va tourner la page
passons à autre chose la faire règle il
fallait le faire ou ouvrir ou reprendre
pour cela trois grands chantiers et ça
veut dire qu'il va pas parler de la
réforme des retraites ce soir je pense
que si on est au terme d'une d'une
séquence et j'imagine en tout cas ça me
paraîtrait naturel qu'il tire les leçons
de cette séquence j'aime chantier et
celui de la justice et de l'ordre
républicain et démocratique
l'État de droit est notre socle et il
n'y a pas de liberté sans loi ni sans
sanction envers ceux qui transgressent
le droit des autres est-ce qu'un jour on
va avoir un chef de l'État qui nous qui
nous respecte qui nous aime et surtout
qui nous considère je pense surtout que
les Français ne l'intéressent pas je
pense surtout que les Français ne
l'intéressent pas le troisième chantier
enfin est celui du progrès
progrès pour mieux vivre je veux que
chacun d'entre vous retrouve la
certitude que nos enfants pourront bâtir
une vie meilleure non non il n'est pas
isolé d'une il n'est pas isolé du tout
c'est clair que l'Élysée c'est un lieu
un petit peu à part mais il y a des
manières de vivre à l'Élysée et l'un
comme l'autre nous vivons pas de manière
isolée mes chers compatriotes
ensemble nous avons fait face à
l'épidémie il y a de nombreuses crises
depuis six ans attendent péril à chaque
fois j'ai cherché à libérer les énergies
à protéger les plus faibles à tenir
l'unité du pays vous nous confirmez vous
n'irez pas demain à l'invitation
d'Emmanuel Macron à l'Élysée non nous
n'irons pas pour une question simple
c'est que moi j'ai toujours dit qu'il y
avait un délai de décence
c'est pourquoi j'ai proposé de recevoir
les organisations patronales et
syndicales dès demain matin pour celles
qui sont prêtes et la porte sera
toujours ouverte le monde du travail est
encore choqué il y a encore beaucoup de
monde qui était qu'à manifester jeudi
dernier et donc il est hors de question
d'aller discuter comme si de rien
n'était sur des sujets
pas et bien nous non plus lundi 20h
concert de casseroles par tout en France
devant les méritent très vite la paix
les repris à toutes les sauces de très à
droite jusqu'à 13 à gauche nous avons
devant nous 100 jours
d'apaisement d'unité
d'ambition et d'action au service de la
France
c'est notre devoir et je vous fais
confiance je nous fais confiance pour y
arriver et puis j'ai également du pâtir
qui se prépare avoir décollé la plus
haute fusée au monde ça se passe aux
États-Unis elle fait 120 mètres de
hauteur c'est la fusée Starship conçue
par Space X du milliardaire Elon Musk un
voltest un peu particulier comme l'a
expliqué à ses abonnés Twitter Elon Musk
propriétaire de Space X ce ne sera
probablement pas un succès si on entend
par là atteindre l'orbite et près de 14
ans après le crash du vol Rio Paris Air
France Airbus ont été relaxés par la
justice française si on s'éloigne assez
du pas de tir avant qu'il y ait un
problème je considérais ça comme un
succès